Iron Man is the greatest of all the heroes
of the Marvel Cinematic Universe — so why
did his solo films stop at three?
In a recent Vanity Fair interview, Avengers:
Endgame screenwriters Christopher Markus and
Stephen McFeely shed some light on why the
Armored Avenger never got a fourth solo outing.
Simply put, the scribes related that Marvel
Studios brass felt that another flick centered
on the adventures of the MCU's most popular
character would've been a little bit too safe.
McFeely made the point that Marvel has never
been particularly interested in doing exactly
what's expected of it.
For evidence, he pointed to its decision to
take a chance on one property in particular
— James Gunn's Guardians of the Galaxy — rather
than cranking out sequels for its most popular
Avengers one after another.
"I recognize this animal.
We'd roast them over a flame pit as children.
Their flesh is quite delicious."
"Not helping!"
McFeely explained:
"Whether you like all of the 24 movies or
not, the capital that Marvel built up allowed
them to do things like make a movie starring
a raccoon and a tree, right?
You would've already had Iron Man 4 if it
was any other studio.
But they decided, 'No, we're going to take
chances on all these other things.'"
To illustrate further how Marvel's affinity
for risk-taking has paid off, the scribes
suggested that we should look no further than
Endgame — the highest-grossing film of all
time, and one that definitively removed Iron
Man and Captain America, the MCU's most recognizable
players, from its increasingly crowded board.
McFeely admitted, quote, "To put a flag in
the ground and say, 'We're going to end something
and take characters off the table' is, I think,
kind of daring, but selfishly it was really
great for us."
Markus then chimed in with the final word
not only on why Iron Man 4 never happened
and never will, but why Tony Stark had to
meet his end at the conclusion of Endgame.
He said:
"[A story] needs an end or it loses meaning.
The end is what cements the thing, to actually
sew it together and bring it to a crescendo,
and yeah, take people off the board, finish
their arcs.
If Tony made it out the other side, and Iron
Man 4 was waiting there, you'd be like, [shakes
head] One too many."
" … That's the hero gig: Part of the journey
is the end."
It just serves to illustrate the extent to
which Marvel has its finger on the pulse of
its audience; it knows them well enough to
not only know what they want, but what they
might not have even known they wanted.
It's true - having Stark defeat Thanos only
to pay a minimal price would have cheapened
his action.
To then bring him back for Iron Man 4 would
have been a transparent cash grab of the sort
that the studio has thus far steered way clear
of.
It's not even that Marvel is opposed to four-quels
for individual Avengers: Thor, after all,
will be getting a fourth solo flick with the
upcoming Thor: Love and Thunder, but he is
a character who happens to be smack dab in
the midst of a huge, profound shift in his
priorities.
His transformation from often-stoic, sometimes
unintentionally funny God of Thunder to hilarious,
clinically depressed, still badass Asguardian
of the Galaxy didn't begin in earnest until
2017's Thor: Ragnarok - and the Earth-shattering
events of Avengers: Infinity War and Endgame
left him with a lot of unanswered questions
about who he really is, and also with a lot
of room for growth.
Stark, on the other hand, underwent a complete
and convincing character arc between inaugural
MCU effort Iron Man and Endgame.
The so-called "genius billionaire playboy
philanthropist" didn't even begin to learn
the meaning of teamwork and sacrifice until
2012's The Avengers, and the events of Iron
Man 3 and Captain America: Civil War forced
him to confront his own shortcomings in a
way that he had never before done.
If Infinity War finally made him come to terms
with the possibility - heck, the cold reality
- of abject failure, then Endgame saw him
learn that even such failure doesn't give
one license to simply give up - and that some
things, like the love of friends and family,
are worth giving everything for.
It was as complete and moving an arc as any
superhero could have ever hoped for.
Of course, this probably doesn't mean that
Marvel fans will never see Iron Man again.
Signs are pointing to at least a cameo in
the upcoming solo vehicle Black Widow - which
takes place between the events of Civil War
and Infinity War - and there are conflicting
reports as to whether Downey will reprise
the role in the Disney+ animated series What
If...?
But as far as Stark's actual, complete story
in the MCU goes, we're of the opinion that
it couldn't have been executed any better,
and that Markus and McFeely are absolutely
correct - Iron Man 4 would have been one too
many.
However, we can't help but hope that Marvel
finds a way to let Taika Waititi keep on making
Thor movies forever.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about the Marvel
Cinematic Universe are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.